by grabthar's hammer water review so
some folks bizarrely continue to go
support me on patreon
at a level that allows them to flat-out
dictate something that I will review and
this month I'm gonna be taking a look at
Galaxy Quest Galaxy Quest is I think at
this point you could almost call it a
cult film it was a decent hit I think a
fair number people have heard of it but
the people who love it tend to really
love it and I do enjoy this a lot now in
case you've never seen it let's start
with a brief synopsis so Galaxy Quest
deals with a Star Trek
esque it's very blatantly based off Star
Trek TV show from decades ago that was
canceled and basically the cast have had
to just ride that very small level of
fame they achieved through that show the
rest of their careers they have to do
conventions and make appearances and and
you know that's that's how they sustain
from there and you know different
members of the cast feel different ways
about that some are just kind of
resigned to it the the guy who got to
believe captain kind of revels in it
other people are super resentful about
it and so that that's your starting
premise and they get taken onto a
spaceship by a race of aliens who saw
their show you know they caught the TV
signals beamed out and this race of
aliens doesn't know what acting is they
don't have fiction in their society so
they thought these were factual
documentaries and they then go and get
this crew to help them with a real
motor space problem on a and I precisely
recreated replica on the ship they used
to pile it on the series and obviously
it's a comedy so let's start with the
cast because this is a great cast your
captain character is played by Tim Allen
now I know Tim Allen is somebody who is
kind of distasteful to to a fair number
of people at this point I'd say but
regardless of what you think of him you
know in life he is good in this part he
is really great at without ever doing a
Shatner impression capturing that sense
of ego of just reveling in the attention
and you know riding it for all it's
worth he gets that really well and he
and that's important because a big part
of what keeps the plot moving for at
least brings the other characters in is
his determination to actually help this
race and actually live up to what they
think he is and if an actor couldn't
sell that the movie would fall apart
immediately but he does and he works
really well for that
I do think Tim Allen's kind of limited
as an actor in terms of the number of
things he's good at but what he's good
at works really well for this part also
we have Sigourney Weaver now I think I
professed my just overall adoration for
Sigourney Weaver in general in previous
videos but oh she's so good she she
hasn't done as many comedies that she
easily could have because she's really
good at it so her her role on the show
was basically all she did was stand
there display cleavage and repeat
whatever the computer said she hurt her
owning of that like not just as an
actress in the movie but as the
character of the actress she's playing
owning that part who she actually turns
to Tim Allen goes look I have one stupid
job on this ship and I'm going
do it I she's so good and the moments
where she gets exasperated she does that
incredibly well there's a part I'm later
on where they're sort of moving through
the ship and there's the ridiculous
inner workings of the ship because again
it was based off the the TV the TV show
that these aliens saw and at one point
why is this here she does these
aspiration wonderfully and of course the
the late great Alan Rickman it has
basically the Spock analog the
classically trained actor who wants to
do theater who wants to do serious
dramatics but is always remembered for
this stupid part on this stupid TV show
and he hates it and nobody does just
that sense of lifelong bitterness like
Alan Rickman he got his voice and the
like without ever raising his voice
without you know but just the venom that
drips from his mouth when he has to
repeat some of these lines that he hates
so much and then we've got actually who
I like who was my favorite character in
my first viewing we have tony shalhoub
playing i he's kind of a ho boy
how do I explain it we don't really know
what's wrong with him
something is very clearly wrong with
this guy because he is not processing
any of this information the way that any
of his co-stars are processing this
information so like this isn't really
spoiler because it's very much of the
beginning so at the beginning when they
get the way they get transported onto
this ship is it's not it's not like
getting beamed up or down like on Star
Trek they get encapsulated in this sort
of gel pod that then shoots them through
space until they land on the ship and
all the other all of his co-stars you
know they'll and they're kind of and he
just land he's like that was a hell of a
thing it's it's wonderful it's brilliant
like I said we never really know what's
wrong with him we don't know if he's
stoned if he was
always like this if like he just used to
do drugs and like had one LSD trip too
many and now this is a permanent state
for him we have no idea what his deal is
which I kind of love I kind of love that
they don't specifically lay out what is
off about this guy but you just get to
enjoy his being off and I think it
actually helps avoid it becoming
problematic because if they had said
specifically
oh he's autistic he you know he smokes
weed you know whatever they could have
done to explain why he is this way could
have made the work problematic because
it you know especially if it's not drugs
and they link it to a specific condition
and you're like oh boy is that accurate
is that you know is that decent raise
that poor representation is that you
know whatever but by not specifying what
it is we just get a guy who's off and
you get to just enjoy that even now how
do you get to just enjoy that and the
the rest of the cast is great too you
have Rainn Wilson as one of the aliens
who's terrific there's there is boy
holy [ __ ] Sam Rockwell's who I've
mentioned in the past I don't like like
not for any particular reason I just
don't like him this is one of the few
parts I'm actually ok with him and
because I'm not expected to take him
seriously or even like him all that much
so he works for me and he's not doing
what I feel is kind of become his stock
character he's a bit more animated he's
a bit more over the top which I enjoy
seeing so his part he was an extra on
the TV show once like one basically one
of the red shirts guy who went down with
the White team and died and he
accidentally gets caught up in all this
which means he is panicking right from
the beginning going I'm gonna die I
played the guy who's died I'm gonna die
and it's it's really it's it's a fun
meta commentary and here's the thing
about this this manages to pull off what
I think a lot of lesser films that have
tried to do a similar vibe and humor it
manages to pull off because a lot of
things like this when they effectively
make fun of a you know a beloved
property and more specifically make fun
of the fandom because they do we see the
fandom depicted you know at the
conventions we get it kind of
encapsulated by a character who just in
long plays and there and obviously the
aliens take this literally so they are
the very embodiment of the fans who take
stuff too seriously and when something
tries to do that very often it comes off
as dismissive as insulting but it
doesn't here because ultimately where
the film goes and how it wraps up it
acknowledges that yes this was a made-up
yeah this is all fake this is all
ridiculous but there's still value in it
there's value in the lessons that these
people have taken
from this show they are lessons worth
carrying in your life they give these
people a community they give them
something to bond around it
it recognizes the positive elements of
fandom while at the same time not
ignoring the sometimes sad elements of
fandom so I I think it strikes that
balance really well I think there's a
big part of why Star Trek fans tend to
like this a lot and you wouldn't
necessarily expect that because you know
fans don't like to be made fun of but
this doesn't feel like maybe funny it
feels this is the kind of humor that
feels like it's made by people who also
love this so it feels like it I don't
know a ton about the the writers of the
director if they are Trek fans but at
the very least they understood how to
approach that and portray that because
it it feels like the kind of send-up
that is done by somebody who genuinely
understands the material and understands
why people like it and why it's
important to them so that goes a long
way towards avoiding what could have
been some real cringy stuff and you know
when it makes fun of Star Trek and shows
like it it does so with legitimate
points and also just gently just ribbing
Lee look like pointing out that the
captain always ends up without a shirt
whenever he's fighting something and you
know all these sorts of things and the
other thing that helps is that it's not
uncommon for these sorts of satires to
get basically get underfunded and they
look cheap so you know you get a lot of
stuff with thats basically just ends up
being elevated fan films you know stuff
like this rarely gets a decent budget
but this does have a decent budget which
means the effects at the time it came
out we're on par with a legitimate
sci-fi film but it's a comedy it's a
parody and
best kind of parodies are always the
ones that at least visually match the
thing they're parody the more you can
look like the real thing the better the
comedy lands and this is able to do that
in a way that I would be surprised if it
ever happens again because try these did
trying to look like a legitimate Star
Wars or Marvel or DC or whatever film is
extremely expensive so the very idea of
of launching an original comedy with the
budget of a sci-fi film yo of a sci-fi
action film that's insane
but they did it here I'm really glad for
it this this is a movie that I laugh
every time and I often laugh at
different things every time and and the
god they cover the gamut with the stuff
that they they pick on right and right
down to the kid who piloted the ship as
a little jab at sort of the Wesley type
characters it's but again at the same
time not hateful jabbing a loving jab
because this is this is a this isn't a
takedown of Star Trek and Star Trek fans
it's a roast and it's the kind of roast
and you know forget fryers clapping you
know the the Comedy Central roasts crap
like that they're just trying to be as
cruel as possible but it's the kind of
roast that happens between friends
between people who know each other love
each other
love the same things but aren't above
just laughing about it because it's
important to be able to do that and if
you've never seen Galaxy Quest before do
like right away I I really strongly
recommend this film it's even separate
from its references the humor works much
in the same way something like airplane
or Blazing Saddles did even if you don't
know the tropes that they're picking
apart the jokes are funny in and of
themselves and you know the tropes it's
all the funnier so if you've never seen
it give it a watch if you have seen it
when was the last time you watched it
seriously I hadn't seen it in a few
years so it was
nice to have it be be brought up for
this so those are my thoughts on Galaxy
Quest have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down the comments
let's talk about it there's a ton of
buttons down there too plus also links
for stuff such as my patreon and you
know check it out if you feel like you
but remember folks you are the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]